nabil karoui toujours entre les mains de
la justice algérienne le chef du parti
qu'elle connaisse la deuxième formation
politique tunisienne après ennahda a été
arrêté dimanche en algérie il lui est
reproché d'être entrée sur le territoire
algérien de manière illégale une fuite
qui a lieu au lendemain du coup de force
du président karzaï est de geler le
parlement et d'interdire à toute
personne visée par des affaires de
corruption de quitter le territoire les
précisions c'est avec notre
correspondant à tunis baisse chez les
hommes d'affaires magna des médias et
chef du parti est calme tounes nabil
karoui arrêté dimanche en compagnie de
son frère le député ghazi karoui pour
avoir pénétré illégalement sur le sol
algérien est toujours entre les mains de
la justice algérienne une arrestation et
qui a eu lieu dans un appartement de la
wilaya de tébessa mise à disposition par
le frère d'un ancien à députés algériens
les pousses de nabil karoui salwa smaoui
qui était également sur place a été
libéré par la police quatre autres
personnes ont été arrêtés lors de cette
opération
nabil karoui pourraient être extradés
prochainement vers la tunisie alors que
l' enquête visant à déterminer des
conditions de son entrée illégale en
algérie se poursuivent dans la ville
tunisienne de castries à la frontière
avec l'algérie la police a procédé à
l'arrestation d'un trafiquant de drogue
soupçonnés d'avoir aidé les frères
karoui a quitté le pays de manière
clandestine selon le parquet de
catherine individu aurait été interpellé
à son domicile et placé directement en
garde à vue depuis le coup de force du
président sayyed plusieurs députés et
hommes d'affaires demeure dans le viseur
du chef de l'état déterminée à mener une
guerre contre la corruption patron de la
chaîne de nessma tv et ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
annabi cawi avait été libéré le 15 juin
dernier après six mois de détention pour
une affaire de blanchiment d'argent et
évasion fiscale